- [Guy] I think I've just
held on to so much pain
and so much anger and
shame over so many things
that are ultimately I
shouldn't be ashamed of.
(upbeat inspirational music)
- Three, two, one, break.
(glass shatters)
(fast-paced instrumental music)
- I'm Diego Torres Caso.
- Hi, my name's Darren.
- My name is Brenden.
- I'm a little nervous.
I honestly don't do much in
front of the camera stuff.
I'm typically behind the camera.
I hope to overcome the idea
of letting others' opinions
stop me from doing things.
- If one person can benefit
from me putting myself out there
and sharing, even if that
one person is only myself,
and this just helps me
heal a little bit more
then I'm okay.
- I hope it'll put me on a fresh page
before I start college
with some more confidence.
- My name is Maxwell Poth
and we are here today
working with queer youth
and we're gonna be photographing them
and creating a beautiful project.
Project Contrast is my photo project
that I've now turned into a non-profit.
I created Project Contrast
to prevent suicide rates
in the LGBTQ youth community.
And we're giving them
the opportunity to become
the advocates that they wanna be
but they just don't have
the platform for it.
There are youth all over this country
who feel alone and afraid of who they are
and a lot of them end
up taking their lives.
They're just gonna leave
hopefully empowered.
- For me, a lot of my
insecurities surround
my struggle with gender identity disorder.
My voice, my it's tough
to talk about you know,
like for me those aspects of my body
just seem toxic and unhomely to me.
- Being in front of the camera, you know,
and having dealt with
like an eating disorder
and just not feeling a lot of worth,
it was difficult.
- My biggest insecurity
is definitely my skin.
But it's like my biggest
insecurity due to the way
that like, other people
perceive me based off that.
And a lot of that though is just me
being insecure within myself.
Because like, maybe they're
not judging me for it.
But like, it eats me alive that like,
the thought that they
are judging me for it.
- Something I think is
helpful to cope with that,
is think of your friends.
Like, some of them definitely
have acne, you know?
But do you know which ones?
Like, I don't.
I don't remember.
- I will make a mistake
on somebody and be like,
oh my gosh, I'm so stupid.
But like, even though
it's just like a word
and like I just like kinda write it off
and like, say it so often,
like, that word actually
has like, meaning to it.
By doing that, like, I
feel like you almost like,
internalize it and start to believe it.
Instead of like, bringing each other up,
or like bringing yourself up,
like, we're kind of constantly
like, tearing ourselves down.
- Even if it's directed
towards someone else,
it's just eating away at you
and your mood or positivity.
- Why are we so careful about
how we talk about other people
but we don't do the same with ourselves?
- [Diego] I wanna let go of the idea
that my identity is a
disappointment to someone.
And that I am letting people down
by expressing who I truly am.
- [Brenden] Constantly
feeling like I'm broken.
- [Darren] My voice, my fat distribution,
my sex characteristics, my height even.
- [Diego] It's something
that I really battle with,
the idea that like, I
can't have a relationship
or I can't be vulnerable with people
because that would require
me to be too honest.
- [Darren] I want to channel
that I don't care attitude.
And really let go of all the things
that have been bothering me.
- [Diego] I stop myself
doing certain things
because of the idea
that it'll be perceived
as me being too feminine.
As if being feminine is a bad thing.
- Just after today, I just
want to keep moving forward.
Because I'm not broken.
I'm not crazy.
Because at the end of the
day, I am a human being.
(upbeat soft music)
(glass shatters)
- Holy...
(guys laugh)
(upbeat soft music)
- [Maxwell] Who do you see
when you look into that photo?
(slow serene music)
- I don't know.
(laughs)
It's like,
I see someone who's like,
strong and typically I don't
perceive myself like that
so it's definitely something
that I want to start looking
in the mirror and seeing
someone strong as well.
I want to look in the
mirror and see someone
who looks like that every single
time I look in the mirror.
- It's new, it's different and it's a side
that I didn't really think other people
would like, get to see like that.
- It was just so therapeutic today.
To just be able to physically
see everything break.
That doesn't make it all better,
that doesn't make it go away,
but I'm happy with who I am.
(light serene music)
- Be yourself and don't
be scared to be yourself.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here
- That was my part.